attends hop hop hop se mérite et c'est
ok quand tu veux c'est parti ouais bon
c'est toi qui commence en du coup ce
pauvre petit break le café je te coupe
la parole ou qui ont souffert comme ça
fait du bien ça va faire
ok donc tu me plie contexte la marche
c'est parti à temps
[Musique]
salut romain ou alors déjà vous allez me
demander pourquoi en rose
bah oui parce que c'est moi le gens qui
font circuler un paquet contre-vérités
sur le sujet au et genre les mecs avec
des perceuses
mais bon ça tourne ça tourne ça lui
revient ça va bien les vacances on n'a
pas le temps beaucoup trop bas tu vois
les couleurs t palatinat
[Musique]
elle est sale elle était bonne pour moi
1 1
un des handicaps congo mais si
l'éjaculation n'intervient pas bon bah
l'érection allen comprends que ce n'est
pas le moment donc épi mais au delà du
principe moral est ce que vous savez
pourquoi bas à la prostate
oui non pas du tout on peut faire ça ça
sera bien parce qu'on sera un peu dans
ton corps
non c'est nul c'est bien et pour ceux
qui connaissent c'est pas forcément à se
les cogner dans une porte tout cas
[Musique]
non parce que vous êtes des fieffés co
s'être mauvaise ambiance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]